пологи neoline мурашкін шановна ж два
місяці не виплачують вони державних
компенсації витрат вже попелу вони на вигляд
пенсії залишилося офіс готова курять зубу
я завтра сланців по нові ти свої
здогадки про статус внутрішню
переміщений вусик диму і буде сказано
реально адреси проживання аличі тканини
прописавши які служби the exam і мають
роботи до грудня показ правду грудня
підготує до нас була продовжена так
адже не морочив відривали слід у
а потім переїхав та when she квартиру
змінив пеклі витку і в результаті нічого на
ранок та ми досі ми нічого не
отримувати виплати прославитися за
виду та сьогодні і нову постановку ряду
може ніби по новій не тільки після
перевірки спеціальні комісії реакція
роботі в краматорську виродки не просто
стрічці з накидкою
поважають сп різним звучанням приїжджав
приїжджав міністр соціальна політика та
сказавши що пориві rca maid with висновок
осел прадо вже 3 немає а перевіряти і по
два-три дні і більше люди сидять
відсікають геть і нікуди не може вийти xii
своїх квартир би не дай боже пройшовши
перевірка та їх застогнати в будинок і ось
тут їх там не застануть заданим і
пузо штатному рідні до міністра
соціальні кулі тикав олександрова
рожкова в краматорську на рази протерти
набив 10 соціальних огидно kill ці
малі пари віри таусі ефективно
замальованих президентів, а їх 72000 то
чи кількість таких писів людей цих
потрібні по рівер це через і снують
ресурсів ціни чоловіка лоб краматорське
мисваком
впало їх рішення взято на роботу ще 20
людей вичинки фінансово не й оргтехніку
простіше на проїзд вона цельсія спробую
години сексу процедура будуть випущені
лічильника деліс одно будуть змушені
чекати заданим рідні камінь та країна
хіба виплати про запи наймаючи ж витрати
не пари свинтил не виплачувати на тілі до
пенсії за крима інвалідам аїди тячів
гаю
руди на маяках народи ви сядете за
встань і сир а вже тут у краматорська
терпіти у людей рвався і в лідку ван і
провели дві акції протестів, щоб нам
чим нам виплачувала повертаєшся в мамі
дотримувалася а від того ж ми живемо of свої
Країни не своїми мовляв і надсилайте продав
і місяцем чиновникам і біля лав
люди одягаються ще в серб миколи
запитала бити він ще два роки цьому
єдиний реєстр переселенців проблем з
документами та виплатами зменшуючи